[Musique]
la nouvelle est tombée
pas de réouverture le 1er février une
situation qui pourrait perdurer
il est très peu probable qu'on puisse
rouvrir mi ou fin février je la
comprends pas et j'aimerais en réalité
avoir des explications une remontée
mécanique alors que les stations sont
visiblement plein ya des gens qui sont
pleines il ya des gens et des gens
que va devenir ce modèle économique qui
risquent de s'arrêter allons-nous
grossir les rangs des chômeurs avec des
centaines de milliers d'emplois
peut-être que c'est ce que l'on veut en
haut lieu
si je prends les urgences de l'hôpital
de grenoble que je connais bien ce sont
1000 la démission par mois aux urgences
qui sont liées à la pratique des sports
d'hiver liés aux remontées mécaniques
or l'hôpital aujourd'hui vous l'avez dit
il est sous tension il a besoin de
soigner les malades du co lead les gens
qui ont des maladies chroniques
on ne peut pas se permettre de prendre
le risque de le saturer fois plus létale
mais jugé 50 à 70 fois plus contagieux
que l'aco vie 19 initiale le vario
anglais pourrait multiplier par trois à
quatre le nombre d'hospitalisations
d'ici deux mois vous citer l'exemple
anglais
on voit là bas qu'il ya une flambée
épidémique une vague épidémique qui
entraîne plus de 1500 morts par jour en
angleterre et qui les a obligés à
confiner longtemps dans ce contexte
l'assemblée nationale a donné son feu
vert pour la prolongation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
jusqu'au 1er juin en dépit de
l'opposition de la gauche comme de la
droite
je peux vous mentir on reste dans une
période d'incertitude et donc vous
parliez du sport de reprendre le sport
etc
la vraie difficulté qu'on a c'est que je
ne sais pas vous dire dans avec
certitude dans quinze jours comment
l'épidémie va évoluer quelles sont les
contraintes qu'elle portera sur la vie
la vie sociale
et si la part de variants c'est le voc
2020 devait augmenter de façon sensible
et que nous devions suivre une
trajectoire allant gleizes le
confinement deviendrait probablement une
nécessité absolue
est-ce que ce confinement ne pourrait
pas être proposé et le conseil
scientifique d'ailleurs la proposer aux
gens les plus à risque qui sont
finalement ceux qui vont être très vite
vacciner qui sont ceux qui sont le plus
à risque d'être hospitalisée de faire
des formes graves
nous allons gagner pas seulement contre
ce virus et ses mutations
mais aussi contre de futures virus dont
nous ne connaissons même pas encore
l'existence
donc oui nous vaincrons la direction
générale de la santé dgs a indiqué
mercredi à apm news que pfizer considéré
depuis lundi que les flacons de son
vaccin anti sascoc deux contiennent si
dose et non cinq comme initialement
annoncé et adapter ses livraisons s'est
pas vraiment en conséquence ses
traditions une tradition en france de
parler souvent des trains qui n'arrivent
pas à l'heure je voudrais aussi vous
parler des trains qui arrivent à l'heure
mieux beaucoup de tracas dans 95% des
cas les choses se déroulent de manière
extrêmement remarquable vous avez dit il
foule que 2021 donc l'année qui commence
marque la sortie du quoi qu'il en coûte
ça veut dire quoi quoi qu'il en coûte
qu'est ce que ça veut dire on était donc
dans un moment de faste et 2 et de
comment dire de de dépenses
inconsidérées
enfin qu'est ce que c'est que ça il a
dit quoi qu'il en coûte mais d'abord ce
n'est pas vrai il n'a pas fait et puis
deuxièmement les dépenses confessons du
deal n'ont pas j'espère nous avons
dépensé d'une certaine manière sans
compter avec le fonds solidarité avec
les dispositifs d'activité partielle qui
sans compter le mode décembre dernier
ont mobilisé plus de 23 milliards
d'euros de dépenses publiques le fonds
solidarité ces 12 milliards d'euros qui
va avec la défiance française c'est
aussi ce qui espèce de traque incessante
de l'erreur il faut au fur et à mesure
de la sortie de la pandémie étendre
progressivement ces dispositifs avec des
paliers avec des resserrements c'est à
dire nous sommes devenus une nation de
2,66 millions de procureur
le président de la république a aussi
voulu renvoyer dans une formule à toutes
celles et ceux qui quotidiennement
parfois plus parfois aussi cacher
derrière l'anonymat de tel ou tel réseau
de tel ou tel profil mettre à profit
chaque instant pour critiquer plutôt que
de proposer
je ne sais pas s'ils sont 66 millions
mais je peux vous assurer qu'ils sont
nombreux